point on se rend compte que les
personnes en situation de handicap
notamment ont été largement oubliée et
donc je suis finissent par renoncer au
soir vous avez proposé deux posters en
fallait que ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
quoi construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
des protestations un peu partout dans le
monde après la mort par asphyxie de
georges floyd à minneapolis le 25 mai
dernier aux états unis des mobilisations
du yuan ou yahoo pourront avoir lieu à
new york à miami ou à washington et en
france trois rassemblements
à paris mais aussi à lille ou à
marseille des milliers de manifestants
ont défilé dans les rues avec pour
slogan justice pour tous
malgré l'interdiction en pleine crise
sanitaire
au liban la population manifeste
toujours contre la classe politique sur
fond de crise économique des
affrontements qui
puis entre forces de l'ordre et
manifestants la mort de l'émir d'al
qaïda au maghreb islamique il a été tué
mercredi au nord du mali dans une
opération menée par l'armée française
annonce faite hier par la ministre des
armées feront ce paris l'algérien
abdelmalek droukdel a été longtemps
perçu comme le chef du jihad a en
afrique du nord et au sahel
mais ils n'avaient plus beaucoup
d'influencé de rôle déterminant sur le
terrain selon les services de
renseignement algériens
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce samedi ces
manifestations un peu partout dans le
monde dans le sillage des émeutes
raciales aux états unis en france des
rassemblements ont eu lieu dans
plusieurs grandes villes des
protestataires qui sont venus dénoncer
les inégalités et les violences
policières des manifestations non
autorisées à paris trois cortèges et une
place de la concorde complètement
barricadés par des policiers un
rassemblement en cours à l'appel de la
ligue de défense noire africaine près de
l'ambassade des états unis
on va rejoindre tout de suite au champ
de mars pour faire le point sur ces
manifestations à notre reporter lit la
femme ouzou bonsoir lit la fin vous avez
suivi ces manifestations contre les
violences policières et les inégalités
raciales
quelle a été l'ambiance sur place
alors là l'ambiance a été très calme
notion d' en direct l'ambiance était
très calmement jusqu'à présent il y
avait plusieurs centaines de personnes
qui ont fait le tour 1 2 sur le champ de
mars les jeunes on y avait beaucoup de
jeunes parmi les manifestants ils ont
chanté ils ont réclamé que justice soit
faite pour toutes les victimes de
violences policières tout se passait
bien mais là il ya quelques minutes
après que les forces de l'ordre et
demandé aux manifestants donc de quitter
les champs de mars de partir à les
tensions commençaient à monter entre les
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre et
donc là je sais pas si vous le voyez
derrière moi sur les images de nicolas
winckler donc là il commence à y avoir
des tensions entre les manifestants et
les forces de l'ordre qui ont sommé les
manifestants de partir et le ton
commence à monter les manifestants
commencent à se demander des termes tels
que police assas en justice pour adama
justice pour georges floyd mais c'est
vrai que ce slogan de police assassin
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'entendait
pas jusqu'à présent dans ces
manifestants dans cette manifestation
qui joue les dit tout à l'heure avec
commencé vraiment dans le calme
et là c'est vrai que les tensions sont
en train de monter de plus en plus ici
et on sent que ça pourrait très vite
avait généré on entend même des gens des
gens insulter les phases de l'ordre là
donc
je comprends qu'on semble on sort ça
commence vraiment que ça pourrait très
vite dégénérer que cette bonne ambiance
de type du début pourrait prendre fin
assez rapidement ici merci beaucoup lit
la femme ercis pour toutes ces
précisions on va faire le point à
présent place de la concorde à paris qui
a été complètement barricadée par les
forces de l'ordre va rejoindre notre
reporter nadège ad razak bonsoir nadège
vous êtes place de la concorde est
apparemment la manifestation a été
évacué dans le calme
ou pas
[Musique]
c'est ça magali évacués dans le calme
blake lively matters comprenait en
français la vie des noirs comptent et
c'était le slogan phare de cette
manifestation aujourd'hui place de la
concorde un rassemblement à l'initiative
de la ligue de défense noire africaine
qui s'est déroulée dans le calme et la
bonne humeur même si on a constaté
quelques moments de tension lorsque
plusieurs manifestants et bien ont tenté
de forcer un barrage policier pour
manifester devant l'assemblée nationale
manifestaient devant la statue de jean
baptiste colbert celui qui était à
l'origine du code noir donc l'objectif
de cette manifestation aujourd'hui
c'était de dénoncer le racisme dénoncer
les violences policières et rendre
hommage à georges floyd c'est un noir
américain de 46 ans qui a perdu la vie
lors d'une interpellation policière
musclée le 25 mai dernier rendre hommage
également aux victimes françaises comme
adama traoré cédric joue via ou encore
un mois m de gaffe si je vous propose
d'écouter quelques manifestants je n'ai
pas juste un problème de violence simple
violence parce que nous sommes des
humains aujourd'hui c'est s'aider
assassinat programmé
on nous tue parce que nous sommes noirs
tout à l'heure on est passé à côté
ferrer qui passait la bague qui disait
on vous attend là bas de toute façon
donc c'est voilà c'est ça devient un
passe temps ça devient un plaisir c'est
ça devient malsain et en 2020 c'est très
choquant fin sur déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen les hommes
naissent libres et égaux en 789 236 me
années plus tard on en est là où il ya
encore des noirs qui sont dessus et quoi
parce que tant qu'il n'y aura pas une
sorte de un débat plus sur ça et que les
gens ne font en fait les gens ne croient
pas conscients de ce phénomène là s'il
n'y aura pas de changement une
manifestation qui je le disais s'est
déroulée dans le calme et la bonne
humeur une manifestation qui était
pourtant interdite par la préfecture de
police de paris qui craignaient des
débordements interdite et également par
l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui proscrit
tout rassemblement de plus de 10
personnes une manifestation qui s'est
plutôt bien déroulé 1 grâce notamment
aux manifestants au dispositif de
sécurité est les forces de l'ordre se
sont tenus à l'écart tout le long de
l'après midi n'ont procédé à aucune
verbalisation avant et bien que cette
manifestation se termine aux alentours
de 18 à 19 heures donc dans le calme et
la bonne humeur à évacuation par le
métro pour la majorité des manifestants
merci beaucoup d'adeptes pour toutes ces
précisions et merci également à lionel
girard pour les images des
manifestations interdites pour raison de
crise sanitaire certains politiques
dénoncent l'inaction des pouvoirs
publics et le laisser faire ces cadets
les honneurs beisel et conseiller
régional rassemblement national de
provence alpes côte d'azur écoutez je
m'étonne également de la mollesse de
christophe castaner de faire respecter
ce faire respecter ce cette phase de
confinement et en autorisant enfin
autorisant en laissant le champ libre à
ces manifestants qui crachent leur haine
de la police
donc je m'étonne en fête de l'amour de
la mollesse du ministère de l'intérieur
qui ne défend pas ses policiers et on va
prendre tout de suite la direction de
marseille pour continuer d'en parler
avec jean marc coppola conseiller
municipal communiste de la ville de
marseille
bonsoir jean marc coppola merci d'être
avec rt france
tout d'abord votre votre réaction sur
ces manifestations un peu partout en
france et également à marseille en plein
confinement en pleine crise sanitaire
pardon oui mais écoutez comme ça a été
soulignée on retrouve beaucoup de jeunes
dans ces manifestations qui expriment de
la solidarité avec le combat des
afro-américains et des progressistes
d'outre-atlantique
mais ils veulent aussi dénoncé les
violences policières dans l'hexagone
comme celle subie par adama adoma adama
traoré une affaire qui dure depuis
quatre ans sans que justice soit faite
et très franchement ce ne sont pas des
amalgames parce qu'aujourd'hui la colère
gronde contre les atteintes aux libertés
et contre la liberté de s'exprimer y
compris contre le droit de manifester il
y a
certes aujourd'hui des sanctions contre
des policiers qui commettent des délits
contre le racisme et elles ne sont pas à
la hauteur d'un corps social qui est
censé protéger
donc voilà c'est il réclame de la
justice ils réclament la fin de tout
délit comme le racisme de toute violence
parce que je crois qu'aujourd'hui je le
dis tranquillement rien ne justifie
aucune violence mais il ya urgence
artix et de la confiance et donc à
laisser s'exprimer aussi ceux qui
expriment d'aider des droits humains
regardez par exemple les manifestations
des acteurs culturels
ce sont des gens qui aujourd'hui sont
sans droit du fait de la crise sanitaire
et qui se font justement violente et
donc la crise sanitaire a bon dos pour
empêcher des manifestations mais en même
temps je crois qu'il faut entendre en
même temps les cris contre les
discriminations et les injustices
sociales a bon dos pour interdire les
manifestations pour vous on devrait les
les autoriser le risque est finie selon
vous non les risques de pas fini mais je
crois qu'on a vu aussi des français qui
sont responsables et qu'ils sont
capables aussi de se rassembler avec des
règles de distanciation justement pour
se protéger et protéger les autres et
donc je crois que ce n'est pas
contradictoire d'avoir à la fois d
expression
de droit d expression de 2,2 donc
l'expression de manifester et en même
temps de faire attention aux règles
sanitaires
est ce que les policiers en portent
l'entière responsabilité
c'est vrai que il y a des des zones qui
n'ont pas forcément été très suivie par
le gouvernement d'aider des zones où les
aides ne sont pas forcément
arrivée on a vu pendant le confinement
toutes ces personnes qui avaient du mal
à le respecter parce qu'elle vivait dans
des conditions assez difficiles ces
émeutes aussi pendant le confinement
enfin ces émeutes contre la police
est-ce que c'est pas la police qui
portent à bout de bras finalement tous
ces problèmes danser dans ces quartiers
notamment ben oui ces derniers remparts
ou sans tout casser les c les fusibles
vous avez tant qu'on ne réglera pas y
compris dans les zones de non-droit des
questions de chômage de discrimination
des chômage qui atteint par exemple les
50% dans certains quartiers de marseille
si on n'agit pas sur l'éducation sur la
formation sur l'emploi les moyens de
vivre dignement effectivement on aura
ces affrontements donc le pouvoir en
place plutôt que de criminaliser
justement les actions collectives les
manifestations et bien ferait mieux de
s'attaquer aux causes aux racines du mal
pour justement trouvé de la quiétude et
du vivre ensemble partout
que pensez-vous on a vu ces
manifestations se déroulaient quel
moment
aujourd'hui alors que les petites
manifestations de gilet jaune ont
toujours été réprimés quasiment
immédiatement
vous pensez qu'il ya deux poids deux
mesures ou pas non il ya une vraie
volonté de criminaliser l'action
collective les manifestations vous
parliez des gilet jaune mais je pense
aussi aux aux actions syndicales de
façon à réprimer toute expression
contraire ah j'allais dire à la pensée
unique à ce que porte le pouvoir on est
dans une démocratie il faut ne faut pas
avoir peur justement de la confrontation
d'idées du débat d'idées on est dans un
pays qui est très politisée et dans ce
pays politisé il faut entendre les
jeunes les moins jeunes
parce qu'ils souffrent parce que les
droits sont en régression
eh bien il faut entendre cela pour
régler justement toutes ces questions de
justice sociale d'inégalités et donc
voilà on est capable de vivre dans la
dignité mais il faut l'entendre et je ne
sens pas la volonté malgré cette crise
sanitaire malgré ce qu'a dit le
président de la république sur les
enseignements qu'il tire de cette crise
sanitaire
je n'entends pas avoir justement des
actions très fermes très forte justement
pour régler les injustices sociales les
inégalités les 10
remy nation et le racisme et le racisme
est d'autant plus intolérable
effectivement quand ça vient du corps
social la police qui est sensé ou la
gendarmerie qui est censée justement
j'allais dire défendre et protéger
justement nos concitoyens merci beaucoup
jean marc coppola d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france en allemagne
également mobilisation en hommage à
georges floyd des milliers de
manifestants beaucoup de jeunes vous le
voyez habillés en noir et masqués pour
certains ça se passe sur la place
alexander platz à berlin et des slogans
comme pas de justice ou ou pas de paix
l'allemagne n'est pas innocente
voyez là est ce qu'on dit c'est
manifestants justement je ne pense pas
que ce soit une situation similaire mais
nous devons défendre tout le monde
c'est pour ça que nous sommes ici je
suis ici pour promouvoir
l'autonomisation des gens de couleur
parce que comme nous l'avons vu
récemment
ils sont opprimés non seulement aux
états unis mais dans le monde entier
nous devons lutter contre le racisme et
les violences policières
cela ne doit pas avoir lieu sur cette
planète c'est pour ça que je suis là
pour m'y opposer nos vies ne compteront
pas tant que les vies des noirs ne
compte pas la solidarité internationale
est importante si nous ne soutenons pas
tous l'importance des vies noir la vie
de nous tous n'aura aucune importance
il y à des noirs dans tous les pays
partout dans le monde et les gens du
monde entier doivent se demander quelle
est la situation des noirs des
communautés noires dans leur pays
[Musique]
je suis ici pour tenir une pancarte
parce que j'estime qu'il est très
important de montrer qu'il ne s'agit pas
de race il s'agit des gens peu importe
si cela se passe aux etats-unis ou dans
un autre endroit du monde
il faut sortir et montrer que nous
sommes tous les mêmes et des
manifestation est également prévue aux
états unis à new york à miami ou encore
un à washington 2
vos défilés sont organisés aujourd'hui
contre les inégalités raciales et contre
la répression policière
plusieurs vidéos circulent d'ailleurs
sur les réseaux sociaux ces derniers
jours elles montrent souvent des
interventions musclées sur celle-ci
filmé jeudi à un septuagénaire a été
bousculé par des forces de l'ordre à
buffalo dans l'état de new york
il a été blessé à la tête hospitalisé
mais se trouve actuellement dans un état
stable mais néanmoins grave
les deux policiers impliqués ont été
suspendus en réaction 57 membres de la
police de buffalo ont quitté leur poste
en signe de soutien à leur collègue
et hier donald trump a mentionné le nom
de georges floyd lorsqu'il a parlé de la
baisse surprise du chômage allusion
qualifié de méprisables par son rival
démocrate à l'élection présidentielle
écoutez nous avons tous vu ce qui s'est
passé la semaine dernière
nous ne pouvons pas laisser cela se
produire avec un peu de chance
georges nous regarde en ce moment et se
dit que ce qui se passe pour notre pays
c'est une bonne chose
c'est un grand jour pour lui c'est un
grand jour pour tout le monde
c'est un grand jour en termes d'égalité
les derniers mots de georges floyd je ne
peux pas respirer
je ne peux pas respirer on tue un écho
dans tout ce pays
et honnêtement dans le monde entier que
le président tente de mettre d'autres
mots dans la bouche de georges floyd
c'est franchement abjecte et le fait
qu'il l'ait fait le jour où le taux de
chômage des personnes noires à augmenter
le taux de chômage des personnes
hispanique à augmenter le taux de
chômage des jeunes personnes noires a
augmenté vous dit tout ce que vous avez
à savoir sur cet homme et sur ses
priorités 15 mar
des manifestations au liban aujourd'hui
contre la crise économique et la classe
politique dominante qualifié de corrompu
place des martyrs des centaines de
soldats et de policiers ont été déployés
sur les principes et les principaux axes
routiers de la capitale et en banlieue
des affrontements ont opposé les
manifestants aux forces de l'ordre des
manifestants qui appelle également au
désarmement du hezbollah on en parle
justement avec nadim gemayel député à
beyrouth un bonsoir monsieur jemaiel
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
comment expliquer le regain de tension
au liban qui a aussi été confinés
comment expliquez-vous ce regain de
tension et ses manifestations contre le
pouvoir
tout à fait donc d'avoir ça fait plus de
deux mois que nous sommes confinés donc
le déconfinement a commencé à beyrouth à
partir du 5 5 juin donc le 6 était une
date pour reprendre les manifestations
qui ont commencé le 17 octobre et et les
slogans de base ou bien les sujets qui
devaient à traiter dans cette
manifestation était tout d'abord la
démission du gouvernement actuel qui n'a
réussi à rien faire durant ces six mois
durant en plus de 100 jours de règne de
gouvernement deuxièmement une élection
législative prématuré et la demande pour
des élections législatives prématurée
afin de renouveler la classe politique
et de reprendre une certaine légitimité
populaire pour pour le pouvoir et
malheureusement le facebook là aussi a
pu imposer une certaine autocensure à
tous les manifestants en ne demandant
pas
le retrait des armes illégales du res
bola et surtout l'application de la
décision
15 59 et 17,01 des nations unies qui
réclame expressément le dépôt de tous
les armes du hezbollah et de tous les de
toutes les factions militaires armés au
liban illégale car ça c'est une
revendication de longue date au liban
justement que le hezbollah déposent les
armes
pourquoi est ce que le hezbollah on le
sait fait figure de police au liban non
le hezbollah ne fait pas je ne fais pas
du tout figure de police au contraire il
fait ses leçons
le la fonction aujourd'hui du hezbollah
est un juge arbitre joueurs au sein du
du pouvoir politique et surtout de la
balance politique tout d'abord mais
surtout c'est un c'est un régime
dictatorial s'éteint c'est un régime qui
est sous la botte iranienne et qui ne
souhaitent que imposer son sa politique
et sa mouvance politique à tout le
peuple libanais ce que nous refusons
carrément et cela il est prêt à le faire
par la force par la force de ces arbres
et c'est ce qui se passe durant à ce qui
se passe c'est ce qui s'est passé durant
les dix dernières années et si la seront
prédominants en termes de maintien de
l'ordre en tout cas c'est parce que
l'état a failli selon vous disons
quelque part que c'est pas l'état qui a
failli disons que hilare et le hezbollah
réussit à mettre toutes les institutions
militaires et sécuritaires de l'état
sous la botte du hezbollah très
simplement
surtout après l'invasion de beyrouth les
le 7 mai 2008 le football a envahi
bayrou dont on se rappelle très bien il
a commis plusieurs meurtres il ya eu
plus de 60 à 110 tués et à ce moment là
c'est toute la structure politique et
sécuritaire du pays qui est tombé sous
la botte du hezbollah aujourd'hui nous
sommes sous sous la tutelle ou bien sous
le gouvernement direct et la décision
direct qui a lui-même imposé sa loi
électorale qui a lui-même imposé le
président qui lui qu'il voulait qui a
lui-même imposée le gouvernement actuel
et c'est lui aujourd'hui qui dirige qui
contrôle le tout tout tout le pays
aujourd'hui nous sommes le liban est un
et 1 est un babrak karmal le
gouvernement est un bazar kermel le
gouvernement et ressemble très similaire
au gouvernement de vichy qui est qui et
soul sous la tutelle des iraniens et du
hezbollah et cela est pour nous
inacceptable nous ne sommes pas
aujourd'hui dans un liban indépendant et
souverain qui contrôlent ces ions d'une
façon autonome et d'une façon
indépendante
cela est inacceptable pour nous et c'est
pour ça que nous exigeons aujourd'hui la
levée des armes et de la mainmise du
hezbollah sur les décisions politiques
libanaises
parmi les autres revendications il y
avait également la corruption de l'état
vous pensez que ces manifestations vont
pouvoir changer les choses tout à fait
aujourd'hui la grande revendication
aujourd'hui des manifestants était une
revendication sociale économique parce
que nous nous vivons aujourd'hui dans
une situation très très très précaire au
liban mais mais malheureusement à mon
avis là la solution ou bien la raison
essentielle du de ses problèmes
économiques et le choix économiques que
nous avons pris au liban depuis les 15
dernières années qui est un choix
économique très similaire aux régimes
syrien et iranien
et nous avons abandonné notre notre
volonté de se battre pour un régime
économique libérale capitaliste libérale
et indépendant et aujourd'hui on en paye
le prix
socialement on en paye le prix
économiquement et pour résoudre ce
problème économique et pour que les pays
occidentaux viennent nous aider
et pour qu'il puisse nous aider pour
qu'ils puissent nous nous donner nous
prêter des fonds
nous devons nous libérer politiquement
du joug iranien et syrien et du
hezbollah
jeudi dernier il ya une réunion
justement à ce propos entre le fonds
monétaire international et le
gouvernement libanais une solution est
envisageable
nous sommes en train de négocier pour
les solutions mais comme vous le savez
les solutions du les solutions du
gouvernement ou bien les wii et des
solutions du gouvernement ne sont pas en
train de prendre en ne sont pas en train
de prendre en considération les grands
schl et les grandes conditions du fmi
qui sont le contrôle des frontières le
contrôle des ports et de l'aéroport et
surtout beaucoup de décisions relatives
à alex et de fonctionnaires dans l'état
qu'ils sont nous le savons très bien
qu'ils appartiennent à une certaine à
une certaine disons groupes politiques
et donc aujourd'hui les grandes
décisions et grand élégant changements
sont des changements politiques ce ne
sont pas seulement des changements
économiques ou sociaux et cela dépend
aujourd'hui de ce que je veux ce que je
vous ai dit tout d'abord précédemment ce
qui contrôle les frontières sont ds bola
aujourd'hui entre les frontières libano
syriennes ceux qui contrôlent le port et
l'aéroport c'est le football a avec
césar ceux qui ont l'excédent dans les
faux dans les fonctions publiques c'est
les adhérents au parti en partie shalit
est donc aujourd'hui la les solutions
économiques sont des solutions
politiques et non seulement des
solutions économiques et la conséquence
c'est que 35% la population est au
chômage
au liban à 45 % de la population vit
sous le seuil de pauvreté au quotidien
comment est-ce que les libanais
gère cette situation écoutez c'est très
très difficile la dernière période a été
masqué un peu par le fait d'avoir des
d'avoir eu le corona et nous avions été
en confinement pendant plus de deux mois
donc plus ou moins la situation était
masqué ils ont contrôlé limité mais je
crois que dans les quelques semaines à
venir les libanais vont commencer à
sentir le poisson fils de pierre le
poids de de cette situation économique
et sociale et ça va être à mon avis une
nouvelle catastrophe et une nouvelle un
nouveau départ pour des affrontements ou
bien pour de nouvelles manifestations
merci beaucoup nadine jemaiel d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur leur terrain
sera pas merci à vous elle est députée
du parti chrétien kateb haut à beyrouth
merci beaucoup c'est un parti libanais
avant d'être chrétien merci à vous la
mort de l'émir d'al qaïda au maghreb
islamique il a été tué mercredi au nord
du mali dans une opération menée par un
l'armée française l'annoncé a été faite
hier par la ministre des armées
on se parlait est l'algérien abdelmalek
droukdel a été longtemps perçu comme le
chef du djihad en afrique du nord et au
sahel mais ils n'avaient plus beaucoup d
influence et de rôle déterminant en tout
cas sur le terrain aujourd'hui selon les
services de renseignement algériens
écoutez florence paris le 3 juin les
forces armées françaises avec le soutien
de leurs partenaires on neutralise l
émir d'al qaïda au maghreb islamique
abdelmalek droukdal et plusieurs de ses
proches collaborateurs lors d'une
opération dans le nord du mali
abdelmalek droukdal membre du comité
directeur d'al qaïda commande l ensemble
des groupes caïd east d'afrique du nord
est de la bande sahélienne dont le j ai
ni m l'un des principaux groupes
terroristes actifs au sahel et voyez à
présent l'analyse d'emmanuel dupuis lé
président de l'institut prospective et
sécurité en europe
expert en questions de défense et de
stratégie
le leader comme s'est présenté d'aqmi
n'est qu'un des nombreux
émir qui malheureusement continuent à
tuer dans cette région 4000 civils sont
morts en 2010 9500 soldats des forces
armées sahélienne également et on le
sait malheureusement 43 français dont le
dernier le 4 mai dernier donc c'est une
victoire symbolique avec si j'ose dire à
un vieux un vieux routier de la lutte
anti tank de la lutte terroriste dans la
région
adam malek troupes elles étaient
d'origine algérienne c'est la raison
pour laquelle il a été mis hors d'état
de nuire dans une région bien précise
celle du reste ou avait été menée des
premiers combats de lauga sur serval
celle qui avait précédé le passo par cal
donc dans une zone dans lequel un
certain nombre de groupes armés
terroristes avaient déjà trouvé refuge
en 2013
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité sur notre antenne on se
retrouve dans 30 minutes rester avec
nous
[Musique]
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre elle les musées avec trois mois
de non activité où les billetteries sont
à l'arrêt l'impact financier est énorme
ce sera un redémarrage sous conditions
avec port du masque obligatoire
distanciation physique gestion des flux
ce que nous attendons c'est
effectivement la possibilité de rouvrir
sans ces mesures barrières le plus vite